did you ever have like conversations
with your daddy or mom when you're
really little like about like what
you're gonna do for a career for a
living when you grow up
did they ever talk to you about that or
you and your brother yeah because I got
the talk a lot like what would they say
to you know you dad would be a last
person that would say that yeah for sure
but I mean I I kind of always had money
saved up though I never really said
money was good right yeah you really
don't spend that much money now besides
the Tesla yeah and some other things but
I don't spend chit for money you barely
wear shoes as it is no I have a good
shoe collection that's probably the one
the only things actually do spend money
on its shoes and clothes yeah in that
early pay right what did you did you
ever like think like what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do for a living what am I gonna do
when I get older how am I gonna make
money or did you just always feel like
this is what I'm [ __ ] gonna do if it
fails it fails I don't know I mean like
did you think about that a lot yeah I
was trying to make it work like even
like three years ago like I was signed
to organizations in paid salary making
money off which like I was never like
it's not like I was like I mean I was
being pretty terrible money but I don't
know what she's doing because you made
salary yeah like I was I got picked up
by like my first or like three years ago
oh really I played hnz oh and
professionally and then one over the pub
he played that professionally it's like
I was never really and I had money like
saved up from playing destiny cuz like
when I first got like partnered on
Twitch I was like a hundred subs which
is terrible but I was making more money
than like my friends whatever you're
making more money than kids that had
like regular jobs yeah and how long did
that last for like how long did you have
a hundred or less subs on Twitch making
a few years really yeah I think like I I
was doing pretty good at first and
like I don't know I stopped playing
destiny to go play pop G and that's when
like my my channel started to like die
down a little bit I would drop down like
100 200 subs maybe really and I started
playing for tonight and then obviously I
took off because of that game when did
that game come out 1 4 9